[Music]
marine biologist quarterly oh Ruby
you're still reading this trash humans
don't know everything about the ocean
mom there's a whole world down there
that I have never seen jellyfish
Plankton coral reefs but what else lives
there I know monsters and those monsters
want to hurt Krakens like us this is
where we belong Oceanside is our home
then help me fit in by letting me go to
prom Ruby the answer is no
[Music]
let's all have a very human day does it
bother you guys that we lie to everyone
all the time oh we're not lying we're
just omitting yeah okay I remember
anyone else we're from Canada this isn't
just any party this is prom and I really
want to be a part of it we
all do yeah no I get it you guys should
go without me it's one thing for my mom
to ruin my life she doesn't have to ruin
yours uh what if you don't tell her
exclamation dragon's right your mom
doesn't have to know deception I'm on
board come on Ruby do it do it I want to
but if my mom finds out oh life is not a
dress rehearsal it's time for you to go
big and go to from okay okay okay okay
you're right
okay I'll do it
look at a prom yes yes so
what's up Chelsea about last night I am
sorry that I ranked apologies are so
corny just skip to the part where you
tell me everything look I
you're here on land one day and you
already fit in I've been here all of my
life and I still feel like a freak
I just want to be Ruby Gilman normal
teenager oh boo where's the fun in that
Ruby you're a giant Kraken don't you
think you could aim a little bit higher
than normal teenager
oh my cute little floppy baby guppy girl
you know what you need great hair in a
mermaid tail
no but it would help what you need Ruby
Gilman is to see how great your life
could be you need a super sea girl ditch
day okay let's do it yay
[Music]
I really really wanna get to know you
Connor would you do me the honor of
going to human prom with me oh Ruby yes
don't give me the happiest guy on dry
land Ruby
Connor Ruby Ruby
hi
Connor's here uh yeah Connor's here
oh
hi hi hi hi
uh we're still on for our tutoring
session later right oh
yeah Connor we are on like polygons all
right team math I'll see you later you
know it anything for my algebra you're
what now I mean
work bro like you're my brother you're
my math brother
I think I like the first one better
[Music]
give me that confetti cannon yeah
foreign
[Music]
Ty the women in our family have the
mighty power to turn into giant Kraken
but what now Ruby you're a princess
aggress the crowd
I think
I am having a panic attack
okay Ruby have it completely totally
ordinary daddy you got this
[Music]
all right
I feel like a freak ow I just want to be
Ruby Gilman normal teenager oh boo
where's the fun in that you have powers
beyond your imagination
are the protector of all the oceans
creatures it's up to you to stop the
evil mermaids but people love mermaids
of course they do people are stupid
show me how to use my power are you
ready
let's see what you're capable of
body armor laser
almost
it's time to go big
uh we're still on for our tutoring
session later right oh
anything for my algebra you can do what
no I mean bro
algebra like you're my brother you're my
math brother
you know I think I like the first one
better
[Music]
the ocean one of the most beautiful and
mysterious places on earth and its most
majestic inhabitant the mermaid stories
have told us that these are lovely
charming and peaceful creatures
unfortunately those stories are very
very wrong
this is the true face of a mermaid note
her vicious claws her pointy fins teeth
that bite harder than a great white
shark and while some may call this smile
Charming don't be fooled mermaids are
the most dangerous of all sea creatures
far more dangerous than the Kraken
although Kraken have historically been
viewed as monsters the truth couldn't be
more different they are awesomely sweet
perhaps a little awkward but powerful
creatures who serve as Protectors of the
ocean mermaids on the other hand are
violent and unpredictable they wish to
control the ocean and will stop at
nothing to get
they are also selfish vain narcissists
with frankly mediocre hair if you
encounter a mermaid do not attempt to
befriend it swim don't paddle to your
nearest place of safety mermaids the
true Monsters of the underwater Realms
you have been warned I'm a flipping
mermaid
the ocean is a Mysterious World humans
know more about the surface of Mars than
the floor of the ocean and the sea
creatures who live there well even the
ones you have imagined you've imagined
them wrong take the mighty giant Kraken
bloodthirsty monster Sinker of ships
where are you even getting this Krakens
are majestic creatures and Noble
protectors I'm just Ruby Gilman normal
teenager for Generations Krakens have
protected the Seas keeping us safe from
the most power-hungry and dangerous
creature of all the mermaid yes the
mermaid but people love mermaids
um they do people are scared
mermaids are selfish vain narcissists I
am quartus yes Queen the worst of them
all
hey are you okay I know your secret
you're a kraken hiding is a human you
really gotta go now and soon everyone
will know the truth
are you ready for your destiny I just
want to live my life
you have powers beyond your imagination
is your moment Ruby
[Music]
hide anymore
Grandmama I want you to teach me how to
use my Powers camouflage super speed
body armor let's see what you're capable
of
I have laser eyes yes they do pack a
Wallops
you're just a dumb teenager
hahaha
a flipping mermaid knock knock no matter
what the challenge a kraken will always
answer us all it's time to go big
[Music]